white has nothing else to do but besides
that the problem is for black you can't
bring your knight in with a check yet
you would love to plant the Black Knight
on the F4 square but White Queen covers
that square so maybe you just defend
that square Black's Pawn can step
forward to G5 getting that black knight
in
oh but he you know those all those moves
they come with their risks because I
regardless of what the computer says you
know you're going to allow white it's
huge past pawn and uh it's not an easy
decision to make so instead package has
gone for repeating the position as much
as possible
but uh the more he does that the more
time Magnus gets on the clock and the
more confident he becomes yeah and
Magnus now is happy not to repeat the
moves now the black queen can't give
check from behind I feel probably to let
something slip here he's checked from
the wrong angle what is the black queen
doing on this side of the board it could
have grabbed a couple of Pawns on the
other flank and I think that would have
been very safe
but suddenly there's only one last check
available to Prague he only had a few
seconds there okay he's captured a pawn
but now the Queens are coming off Magnus
has found a way to get the Queens off oh
no and this is going to be a turn around
yeah I think Prague forgot about this
track suddenly the Queens disappear look
at the left side of the board white has
two versus blacks one white is going to
promote a pawn just make a new Queen
Black's Knight is too far away
complete turnaround in just one move
the Queens are coming off but look at
Magnus he's not hesitating it's a race
but white is winning the race this Pawn
is captured and White's new a pawn is
too close it's gonna make a new Queen
yeah and there it comes the a pawn is
marching and uh Prague is desperately
moving his Knight to cover the promotion
square and uh here we go white tonight
is irrelevant it's key to go after
Black's piece and uh look at the two
pawns white is clearly ahead in any race
yeah yeah nothing to do Prague has to
move his Knight out of the way
you can move it to G5 you can Retreat it
to f8 with a check either way white is
going to continue chasing that black
knight yeah and unfortunately okay after
this Knight moves to the square you can
actually just capture the pawn and
attack the Knight and you're still
winning and this looks so natural yeah
remove the final defender of that black
knight the Knight has to retreat it has
to blockade knights we say are normally
good blockadas but just again it's these
A and H pawns they're the only Pawn they
struggle against and here we go Prague
is going to resign no way to stop
White's Pawn anymore Magnus does take
the win incredible winning the second
game in a row Magnus Carl